we have two speakers right now it's a
duel
right so one of them spends way too much
time playing retro video games
and the other one spends way too much
time automating all the stuff in his
life
so now we got to figure out which one is
which
everyone please welcome west and john we
all know that
wes bro pandas
not not wrote but
started started yeah but he also put out
a blog post about called 10 things i
hate about pandas
and that came out in 2017
and we all know there was another pandas
book by dan chan that came out in 2017.
it's curious timing for when that book
would have came out so i think we need
for us to change the author of this book
do you want you want me to cross it out
for those of you that don't know it is
our time on our tradition of trolling
wes up here and we have to come out more
and more creative ways every year so
with that oh look i'll show it to the
camera oh yeah here it is that's awesome
can you zoom inside on that that's
awesome wes get in there dan get in
there dan
yeah
yeah
thank you very much for being good sport
as always
thank you sir yeah do you know how we
make this bigger so we can just do it
yeah yeah yeah uh-huh is it glitch here
um
is that good do you want bigger is that
ideally it'd be great to see this slide
but oh so that wait can you rearrange
this
no let me zoom in more i can zoom in
more
just control plus
okay all right but your notes are here
oh i don't need them that's fine yeah
okay good all right cool um you don't
need anything here
okay cool
all right folks uh it's great to be back
i think this is like seven or eight
years in a row it all it all runs
together uh through through the years
but uh it's been a consistent theme in
in the last and last five or six years
um
we started there we started the aero
project and so every year we come back
to share
how things have things have evolved to
to make data processing
faster and easier in r and to make it
easier to work with
work with massive work with massive data
sets so this year um the theme is about
how how arrow is evolving as technology
to to make r more connected with the
broader the broader data ecosystem and
the so-called modern data stack
so we will be sharing some things about
some things about that um
so co-presenting this year so i think
previous years i was here with neil
richardson here today with uh with with
john keane um so just a few words about
myself
i was the co-creator of the co-creator
of the arrow project
had been doing a bunch of a bunch of
things in and around arrow for the last
six seven years
started the pandas project 14 years ago
haven't been super involved in pandas in
the last nine years
i've got a book about python there's
many books about
about python for data analysis now and
john
hi i'm john keane
i work as an engineering manager at
voltron data with wes
and i've worked kind of through my
career after academia switching back and
forth between data science and building
data science tools
so that's one of the reasons i'm super
excited to contribute to apache aero
so we so we started the aero project in
in 2000 uh 2016 and it is involved into
its its current mission which is to be a
multi-language polyglot toolbox for
accelerated uh accelerated data
interchange and in memory and memory
computing it's grown very fast we're
we're getting closer to the you know 10
000
stars on github mark whatever that
whatever that's supposed to mean
and
but you know we have
you know several you know several areas
and mantras that we care about so one is
is language independence uh so building
a software framework that can bring
value
across the the broader uh space of
computing not just a particular
programming language we're building for
the hardware agnostic future being able
to use cpus gpus fpgas different types
of hardware to accelerate computing we
want to provide maximum developer
flexibility enabling people to solve the
problems where they are rather than
having to bend over backwards to use a
technology that's that's an awkward fit
for solving the problem that they have
we started with data representation and
data and data transport and that's still
a core of of what we do it's about
interoperability being able to access
and work with very large data sets with
almost no overhead
and on on that we've we've moved on
to
to building more
computing technology for processing uh
the the aero the aero memory format
um
so we've been through several iterations
of um
of uh structures for supporting aero
development and and getting funding and
for for development uh growing the open
source community project started as an
apache project in 2000 2016
a large collection of open source
projects coming together to develop
community supported standards for data
frames and for tabular data processing
after a couple of years
you know after a couple years of
development for me i was at cloudera and
then two sigma there were many companies
that wanted to pour resources into aero
development so we saw an opportunity to
create a not-for-profit organization
ursa labs
to further the mission of aero and
aeronative computing
without
needing to create products and sell
things so we operated as a industry
consortium funded by hardware companies
financial firms
we
were also greatly uh greatly sponsored
by our studio uh for for those those
couple of years 2020 uh things became a
bit of a whirlwind we spun out uh to
create a startup ursa computing which is
just when john
joined up joined up with me
you know working to to bridge the gap
between the open source ecosystem and
the in the needs of enterprises building
on building on apache arrow
2021
we saw an opportunity to to join forces
with even more folks from the aero
ecosystem
in particular pioneers from the gpu
computing
gpu computing ecosystem to create a
unified
accelerated analytical computing company
which we're calling voltron data
the mission
the open source mission of ursa labs
continues on is voltron voltron data
labs
and you know we continue to you know
we're now over 100 people and you know
many of those you know several several
dozen of which
actively work on the apache arrow
project and the ecosystem
ecosystem around around aero
so i will hand this over to to john to
talk about what this
all means for
an r user and how to make how how uh you
know to make the what we've been
building more concrete in your
day-to-day work as a as an r developer
thanks wes
um so a bit of a recap uh
what does this mean for me as an art
user like how does arrow help me
and what arrow
the kind of overarching project but also
arrow the r package lets you do
is it unlocks a bunch of abilities to
read large amounts of data
quickly and even use query engines that
rely on the arrow format and error of
interchange
so a couple of concrete things you can
do with the arrow r package is you can
read and write parquet files
you can query large multi-file data sets
that don't typically fit to memory
you can write and re-partition those
data sets efficiently
and you can also read data from cloud
storage and many other things and i will
show you a lot about the data sets in a
few minutes
so this sounds cool how do i get it
we've been on cran for a few years now
so you can install that packages arrow
if you want to get the kind of bleeding
edge dev version
and you already have arrow installed we
have this helper function that lets you
get a
bleeding edge version that we build
nightly with install underscore arrow
innately equals true
and then there
are urls for docs there which have
helpful
introductions as well as
things that can be helpful when you're
getting started
if you run those commands and it doesn't
if you run those commands and it doesn't
work please tell us because we will fix
it yes yes
but we have a huge amount of ci testing
all of that so if you do that we might
ask you do you have a docker image that
we could put into our ci but we will do
that and make sure that it doesn't break
again
um so the r or sorry the aero
projected ecosystem has seen kind of
huge growth since it started
we see increases in users contributors
applications that use it
we had our eighth major
release this past may
we have over 75 000
downloads per month of the arr package
and that's actually only one cran mirror
the one that has logs from our studio
we have over 50 million pi arrow
downloads
something i probably should have put up
here as well but west reminded me about
this
last night another
kind of facet of a healthy ecosystem for
an open source package is seeing the
number of contributors over time and
just like these the number of unique
contributors to apache area is
increasing so not only are we developing
more code we're also developing the
community
around that code so that community can
maintain the code going forward
so if anybody joined virtually last
september
west gave
the kind of annual update
and since then we've had a huge amount
of activity both in the core aero
project but also bringing that stuff
into the arrow r package
so since that update which was less than
a year ago it was in september we've
implemented joins for arrow data set
queries
um a number of date functionalities many
of them mirroring the lubridate
functions as well as some base r
date manipulation functions
we have a kind of experimental set up
for extension classes for new types and
i'll talk about
one
very cool use of that in a little bit
and there have been a bunch of quality
of life improvements around data sets so
things like making it easier to
write data sets with exactly the right
types of settings that work with your
data
and of course everyone's favorite
we gain the ability to write csvs we've
been able to read csvs for a while but
we never wired up the writing feature so
you can write csvs
um so looking at what we did uh last
year um we start off with a data set so
you do standard
library arrow library d plier because
we'll be using the the d plier syntax in
querying arrow data sets
so this data set right here
i downloaded to my local computer and
all of these timings that i'm going to
give you are from that that macbook it's
not an impressive macbook it even has 16
gigabytes of ram so not even the max ram
you can get
nevertheless all of these timings and
queries that i'll go through are from
that
this data set itself is the new york
taxi data set
from 2009 to 2022
and so once you open the data set you
have this data set object and you can do
things like figure out how many rows
there are um and so here this is about
1.7 billion rows in this data set
on disk
these are saved as parquet files and
it's 68 gigabytes of parquet files and
the parquet files are actually
compressed so if you were to attempt to
load that into memory you would need
even more than 68 gigs
and i think we all know that 68 is
larger than 16 so there's just no way i
could open this data set and process it
in r in memory
and that's what arrow will let us do
uh so opening the data set uh all it's
doing is scanning the headers of the
parquet files as this is super super
fast it's like .06 seconds to open the
data set
it's read some data so that we know
what's in the data set we know how many
rows there are but it hasn't actually
processed any of the data
[Music]
and this data is all available at this
s3 bucket so if you want to download it
and try it
you can
awesome so we've opened our data set now
what do we want to do so this right here
is is a pretty bog standard
d-player pipeline and something i
kind of joke about when i give
presentations about arrow and using the
d-player interface is if you know
d-player this presentation should be
stupidly boring because you're like this
is d-player you don't need to teach me
filter and we put a lot of work in
crafting narrow the arrow package to use
all of the same d player idioms and make
sure everything just works like it
should that we don't have to learn a new
data manipulation framework or
syntax you can just use what you know
from dplyr and operate on these giant
data sets
so here we're looking at kind of want to
get an aggregate based on the pickup
zone for taxi trips uh what are the
means for things like
total ride amount and tip and stuff like
that
so we start off with very standard d
player verbs right we have a filter
and then we group by the zone
we summarize with mean functions
and then we filter again to say i only
want the zones that had more than 500
pickups
and the only thing that is slightly
different
and you'll be familiar with this if you
use any db player is we have to do a
collect here at the end because what we
do in arrow when you're specifying the
the dpi pipeline it's not actually
calculating anything it's just kind of
setting up a query plan and then that
collect says okay now arrow go run this
query and give me the results
and here we have the results
and the amazing thing here is that this
took just about 10 seconds and again on
my macbook it's not some cluster
somewhere
we processed that uh billions of rows in
10 seconds to get an answer like this
there was i didn't even try to do this
because i knew that r would just crash
but
effectively impossible before
[Music]
and this right here
is everything that you basically could
do last september so what can you do now
um so one of the features that we added
are joined so this data the pickup zone
id is a pretty useless indicator for a
human like i don't know what zone one is
or zone 28.
um but there's a helpful file that gives
you what the zone lookups are in a csv
and so what we can do is we can load
that file as a second
data set that we call zones
we have our same query here where we
filter group by summarize and then at
the end we just do a left join on that
zone lookup and so it says give me you
know the zone ids and match it so that
we can get nice human readable zones and
it turns out zone one is newark uh which
is a little surprising for new york city
taxi data but
i guess you have the outliers at the
beginning
and again uh this is super quick this is
a bit a bit cheating it says seven
seconds i ran it right after i ran that
other query so some of those per k files
are kind of in disk cache uh but even
running this separately without running
that first query uh will be on the order
of 10 or 11 seconds
we also implemented date time
functionality like i said and these you
can just insert into these pipelines
like you would
so this is a same pipeline but i want to
look at by quarter let's group by
quarter year and zone i mean here i just
tossed in the lubridate quarter function
and what this is doing is there's
actually a kind of wrapping or a binding
that takes quarter and then turns that
into the expressions that arrow can use
operating on the native arrow
query and native arrow data it's not
pulling it into r using lubridates
quarter but it's using an implement
implementation in arrows query engine
which means that it's super fast
and this query here took 12 seconds and
again we're querying billions of rows on
a laptop and we get an answer in 12
seconds
so uh kind of stepping outside of
uh just looking at d player queries
um
one of the great things about the aero
format is that is a memory format that
is standardized and you can use it
across languages or across packages and
that standardization makes it so that
different uh packages different
languages can all access the same memory
without ever having to kind of
re-serialize it or save it to disk or
save it to a csv and then read it back
in
and that unlocks a bunch of really cool
functionality
so one of the packages that has
implemented this
is ductdb which is an in-process
sql database
they also have an r package
and the cool thing is you can start out
with an arrow data set
um do some use filtering standard dplyr
stuff and then if you add this to ductdb
verb what it does is it set it passes to
db a pointer to the arrow data center
actually the query that will be run
against the arrow data set
um and then from that point on you're
actually interacting with a tibble or a
lazy tibble
and so you can just do standard d plier
or db plier
functionality after that um and the cool
thing is here we're not actually passing
we're not actually translating the data
at that point we're just saying hey dr b
when you run this query look for this
data here and ductdb can read the arrow
memory directly
and there is
nearly zero transformation to go from
the arrow format into the the kind of
native db format that it processes on
and so this is super quick
this is took 11 seconds and this query
is the same one that we did at first and
so you can see
it took 10 seconds the first time in 11
seconds here so we're not actually
paying a penalty from going from arrow
to duckdb
because of that arrow memory interchange
[Music]
um i'm going to
well this one is quick so you not only
can you go
to duckdb you can also come back into
arrow so if you had a function that you
could only do inductdb or you had some
some custom data in ductdb you could do
two duckdb
do some d plier and then do two arrow
and what that does is it registers the
duckdb result
as something the arrow can operate on
and you can continue on so here we're
doing that lift join after after the
fact and we get results like that
and again
this is 10 seconds so we're not even
paying a penalty we're now you know
going back and forth twice
if we were having to write this to disk
it would just take forever but
because we're just passing the pointer
to the memory reference around
there's no penalty for doing that
um you can also write pure sql um so if
you alter that 2.tb call to give it a
table name and you pass in a connection
you can then just reference that table
in a standard sql
uh query like this if you prefer sql
over to player
another really cool thing and this is a
work in progress it's not yet on crayon
but a colleague of ours dewey dunnington
has been working on this package called
geoarrow which extends the aero memory
spec and also a spec for writing geo
data on in parquet files but using arrow
under the hood
and it's super awesome so this
also is showing
the referencing an s3 bucket with data
in it
and
this data set has 9.4 million rows
and with geo error you can filter that
and again this actually isn't even
downloading all the data first it's just
referencing it in s3
um
it takes about five seconds to read the
headers of the files on s3 and then five
seconds for this query and you get back
geodata this is like well-known binary
format but you can then take that and
use it in sf or plotting
which is really fantastic
um
yes and you can install this with
install underscore github it'll be on
crayons soon but we don't know quite
when yet
so if you want to know more we recently
released in our cheat sheet
and so this is up on our web page
which is fantastic kind of gets you
started and gets you working there's
also a cookbook for r in a bunch of
other languages that aero supports that
have recipes for common workflows um
both of those are really fantastic
so what's next we're going to continue
working on
this project called substrate which we
talked a little bit about last year
didn't talk so much here what that's
doing is it's taking the kind of deep
player syntax and turning into an
intermediate representation
that standardized across engines which
will unlock a bunch of features being
able to send different queries to
different engines and that's a separate
open source project but something that
we are
working with folks there and driving
development on
we also plan to have window functions
which will be coming up soon and there
are a number of performance and
efficiency improvements
and one last thing
neil told me he's been told by multiple
people that aero is not actually a real
r package because
we didn't have a hex sticker but
i'm here to tell you we have a hex
sticker
uh i have a bunch of them i'll go put
them up on the table uh and huge thanks
to danielle navarro who designed this it
was fantastic
thank you
thank you
that was great
i've been asking for this geo-era stuff
for a while so i'm glad all of my
in-person feature requests have come to
fruition
yes
and that is beauty of open source right
you want something you ask nicely and
odds are you're gonna get it
yeah i've had lots of feature requests i
put in just like asking very nicely
either in person or in github and they
come through so that's great so i'm very
i am personally very excited about that
so that was awesome